Shawn is in Indiana says we are pregnant
with a third child we've learned that
the baby has an issue that will be fatal
hmm
heartbreaking my main concerns are that
of the mental and spiritual health of my
family my next concern is that of the
financial impact the baby will be
delivered cesarean so we'll have a lot
of out-of-pocket with the hospital will
then have the costs with how we choose
to lay her to rest I have a good
emergency fund and all in all a pretty
good financial health is there any
advice on how we can plan for some of
the burden ahead Shawn I'm so sorry
well horrible thing to face you know I
found when I'm walking in these
situations with folks and I have sadly
over the years lots of different similar
things that the on the financial side of
the equation and you do have this right
the mental and spiritual health of your
family and it is the primary concern
financial is down the list but they all
affect each other what I tell folks on
the financial side is very simple
pile up cash the bigger the pile of cash
the less you have to think about money
and the less you have to think about
money the more you can concentrate on
the things that matter and money is not
one of them but that's how that's what
money does it's a tool that gives you
it's a buffer between you and the pain
not because money makes the pain not be
there but because you don't have double
pain you don't have to worry about the
cost of laying the baby to rest or the
cost of making sure your wife gets
proper medical care or the cost of dot
dot dot fill in the blank when you have
to worry about that then you can worry
about what's really important which is
not any of those things the cost is not
the important part important part is
your is your is you and your wife and
your kids and the situation so I'm just
going to stop spending any money and say
there's storm clouds on the horizon I
need a bigger umbrella
and I've got to batten down the hatches
so to speak and that means pilot cash
pile up cash pile up cash pile up cash
so that when we walk through this if the
prognosis is correct and I pray it's not
but if the prognosis is correct the the
cash is it you know your gears are just
grinding there's just a lot of friction
in your life there's a lot of heat and
this is just all the cash is just oil
over the gears it makes it run smooth
make sure it makes you be able to not
have to decide you know you don't have
to fret and go making decisions based on
money so the bigger the pile of cash you
can have the easier on the the less of
the financial part you'll have to think
about and the more you can concentrate
on what matters for the rest of you that
are listening to me answer that here's
the equation okay just think about it
for a second let's go if you take some
of this advice and you say let's take it
to a bizarre level and then you think
then it allows you to see what I'm
talking about let's say that that family
had $2,000 cash which they have more
than that because he said he had his
emergency fund but let's say you're
facing something and you have $2,000
cash and you've got 10 or 20,000 dollars
worth of expenses then let's change the
number instead of $2,000 cash let's say
you've got $200,000 cash and you have
20,000 or 30,000 dollars worth of
expenses you see what I mean instantly
you go I wouldn't think about it exactly
that's my point you would not think
about it now I'm not suggesting he has
to and I'm not suggesting he's going to
have 200 either but that's one of the
things that building wealth does for you
and for your family is it allows you to
concentrate on things that do matter we
spend a lot of our lives concentrating
on things that really don't matter
around the subject of money because
money becomes our master in that sense
and Jesus said it's tough to serve two
masters like impossible so PT Barnum
who's an interesting character by the
way side note if you've never read some
of the stuff about him I Barnum and
Bailey Circus right and he was known as
being a great promoter he was
also known as being a great businessman
in a very interesting read when you read
some of the stuff about him he wasn't
just some kind of a character a shyster
or carnival barker or whatever you call
it he wasn't you know charge of the
circus circus is part of what he did but
he said money is a fabulous slave and a
horrible master and I think that's kind
of what Jesus was talking about when he
said you can't serve two masters so
having a you pile of cash to face life's
hardest moments it doesn't make the
hardest moment go away and the money's
not important not saying that at all it
just it just it just gives you options
and you don't have to think about this
stuff that doesn't matter and that comes
down to I don't have to think about
paying my light bill so I can think
about stuff that really matters I don't
have to think about keeping gas in my
car so I can think about stuff that
really matters I was thinking about that
the other day I stopped and filled up my
car with gas on which was a mistake in
the middle of all the Christmas traffic
around this mall that were sitting next
to in this office it's like can't drive
around this place but anyway and I was
filling up the car and I thought to
myself I remember it hadn't thought
about it in years how many times I go to
the gas station and I'm thinking how
much gas can I put in my car how much
money do I have all the way back to
college when I was I mean gas was like I
mean I don't know it was a dollar or
something a gallon or less than that 78
cents a gallon or something like that
when I was in college 100 years ago and
and I'm trying to find the scrape
together and you know nickels and
quarters and stuff out of the couch and
going through the cushions trying to get
enough to put put two gallons in the car
to get to college that week and and how
long it has been since I've thought
about what gas costs and what I was
laughing to myself about was how much my
life has changed because I remember not
having to be able to put gas in the car
and I'm thinking about okay over five
dollars in they'll get me then that we
go and put ten dollars in and get me the
other week I won't put fifteen dollars
in and and the number of times I have
pulled up to a gas pump and not filled
the car up
in the past ten years is zero a hundred
percent of the time in the past ten
years I pulled up I filled it up
completely
now I just laughed myself it's a little
change but just because that no longer
is something I worry about because I've
been living like no one else and now I'm
able to live and give like no one else
and I could turn around and if I thought
to do it and if I saw somebody that
needed it I would and pay for somebody's
gas right there at the pump
somebody was struggling look over and
see somebody that looks like they need
to tank a gas to get somewhere and it
wouldn't change my life it wouldn't be
like I say I just you know now I can't
pay the light bill Tuesday because of a
generous your generosity changes your
ability to be generous changes and
sometimes if you just scale things a
little bit in your mind and that can
give you hope or a way or a direction
it'll it'll outline the principle for
you as to what you're doing and that
means you know what would I give if I
had a half a million dollars in my
mutual funds and I had $50,000 in an
emergency fund and I ran into X Y or Z
situation well kind of a tip would I
leave for the valet or the waiter or the
waitress the guy that brought the pizza
how would I think differently if I
didn't have to worry about money
see that's what we're talking about
every day on the show it's not that
money is the answer but that it changes
your life when you don't have to think
about it anymore
you don't think about it what car you
drive or think about anymore because you
thought about you're going to live like
no one else gonna pay a price to win
you're gonna hustle and grind baby
you're going to live like no one else so
that later you can live and give like no
one else the Bible says no discipline
seems Pleasant at the time but it yields
a harvest of righteousness this is the
Dave Ramsey show you guys would be so
rich so fast and be able to do so much
not only for yourselves and for your
family but for others
you